film box was originally developed to be
a real-time kernel for feedback and
visualization of data for animation it
was put on the map when it was used to
produce the bullet time effect in the
matrix which was obviously very cool so
cool that we're still talking about that
to this day by 2002 the software was
renamed MotionBuilder it's because it's
become a cornerstone technology for
directors pioneering new approaches and
virtual filmmaking its application can
be used at the intersection of previous
onset visualization motion capture and
shot pipeline film box gathers and
processes data from multiple inputs and
devices while rendering and displaying
the results in real time its use is
almost ubiquitous on performance capture
stages and virtual sets the real-time
event processing architecture
development development film box is a
very significant engineering feat it has
enabled virtual production a new way of
filmmaking
so tonight on behalf of the Academy we
are so honored to present the scientific
engineering award to do - Andre Gautier
Benoit Simon a Ivoire so I excuse me in
ro-bear lon Ciel well I didn't have the
luxury I think that my text showed wound
up there so I'll have to read this one
thanks to the Academy for this Plake
it's me it means a lot to us
film box has been a great team effort
there's a lot of people I work on that
the people that would with me on the
stage part and many others worked very
hard on this it's amazing technology we
are truly honored that the Academy is
recognizing the our vision that motion
capture could change the way movies are
prepared are produced from its birth
with Carrara founders Michele Desna
facility and an Taguchi to the people
who made a lot of difference over the
years just to name a few
there's
Luke that is manual Raja
it's an Capano pierre-paul Sheree Sonny
oh there's a lot more like that there's
up to a thousand a hundred people that
worked on that products and finally to
Christianly Ginza Massey Burton Savannah
gosh who with me using film box
foundation which became MotionBuilder
we're later at Autodesk has continued to
evolve as well huh sure in the new era
or virtual production thank you very
much